If you've been with me so far, you know
that nucleus is providing only threads and IPC. It
doesn't provide the abstraction of an address space. Because
this is implemented inside the kernel of the Spring
system. But, it is not what Spring calls as
X micro-kernel because nucleus that contains only the threads
and the IPC. Whereas Liedtke's description says you should
have all three in the microkernel, and in fact,
the Spring system does have it. It is just that in
the Spring system they name things
differently. They call nucleus their microkernel,
but the idea of a kernel in the Spring system contains
all three entities, even though the nucleus doesn't contain the address space.